Niels Bohr was a pioneer of the
radioactive the structure of the atom he
was from Denmark and he was given as far
as I understand he was given a house by
the brewery that the Carlsberg brewery
which was next door to the brewery and
it had two taps in the wall which he
could open and lager would come out and
it is quite an interesting fact that
during the Second World War and the Otto
Hahn and Max Planck to German Nobel
Prize winners gave Bohr Niels Bohr their
Nobel Prizes gold medals to look after
and when Germany invaded Denmark he
wasn't quite sure what he should do so
his colleagues dissolved gold in aqua
regia which is mixture of hydrochloric
and nitric acid the only material that
will dissolve that gold and just left
these beakers of solution on the shelf
and nobody realized it was gold and
after the war the gold was recovered and
the Nobel Prizes were given back to
their winners